bonsoir emmanuel dupuis merci de
répondre à nos questions comment
expliquer ces libérations le colonel
assimile de l'état et l'armée malienne
ont cédé face à la pression de la
communauté internationale dont ils ont
respecté ce qu'ils s'étaient eux-mêmes
engagés à faire à savoir libérer le
président de la transition en benneteau
et le premier ministre moctar ouane je
rappelle que ces deux responsables ne
sont pas détenteurs du pouvoir puisque
contrairement à ce que l'on lit un petit
peu partout et ne s'est pas s'agit d'un
deuxième coup d'état mais il nous sommes
dans une situation qui est illégal par
rapport aux commentaires
car effet un de vos seins de vaud un
duel de vous attendez un des personnes
qu'ils étaient interviewés
il ne s'agit pas d'un deuxième coup
d'état il s'agit de la réaffirmation de
dur retour à la réalité à savoir que le
mali est sortie du cadre institutionnel
avec le coup d'état du 18 août dernier
le président de la transition n'était
que le président d'une transition qui
est dirigé par les militaires
donc les militaires se sont engagés à
les libérer une fois lors des missions
acté ce dont il s'agit maintenant c'est
de savoir qui va succéder à moctar ouane
et si éventuellement il justement à 1,6
me go ita le colonel a dit à la mission
internationale dépêchée à bamako qu'il
comptait prendre la tête de la
transition et nommé un premier ministre
donc quid de cette fameuse transition
dont vous parlez transition civile et
accord des élections mais il sait jamais
s'agit d'une transition civile
c'est pas parce que par un dos était à
la tête de la transition qu'il
s'agissait d'une transition civile et
militaire ou encore le pouvoir les
militaires n'ont jamais céder le pouvoir
depuis le 18 août dernier
la communauté internationale a voulu
passer en force en donnant l'impression
que ce que l'on voit le plus c'était
dans le premier ministre et le président
ont repris le pouvoir des mains des
militaires mais quand vous êtes à bamako
j'en reviens vous avez le sentiment
totalement inverse ce sont bien les
militaires qui dirigent le pays depuis
le 18 août dernier
donc il n'est pas question de céder le
pouvoir et les militaires avec la charte
de la transition qui a été votée le 12
septembre dernier avec la mise en place
du conseil national de transition qui a
commencé à siéger à partir de décembre
dernier avec la mise en place du
processus
de transition a maintenant à faire des
élections en février prochain entre
entrecoupé d'un processus de révision
constitutionnelle et le par le biais
d'un référendum ont répondu aux
injonctions ou aux demandes de la
communauté internationale
plus précisément de la cedeao de l'union
africaine et donc ce qu'on appelle le
comité local en y associant également
l'union européenne et un certain nombre
de pays dont la grande bretagne la
france et des états unis
il ne s'agit pas de dents levé le
pouvoir aux militaires les militaires
ont le pouvoir
il s'agit de changer de responsable qui
d'une certaine façon au commis une
erreur stratégique ou politiques les
militaires disent qu'ils ont franchi la
ligne rouge en eux les consultants pas
sur la nomination non pas de la totalité
des 25 membres du gouvernement mais en
particulier deux responsables politiques
le colonel koné et le colonel camara qui
exerçait les prérogatives les plus
importantes qui selon la charte la
sécurité et la protection civile
la défense les anciens combattants et
choyé aux militaires donc d'une certaine
façon ils ont voulu circonvenir les
militaires et les militaires se sont
rappelés au bon souvenir de la
communauté internationale en rappelant
et c'est un fait dont on va se désole
que le pouvoir n'est plus civil le
pouvoir et militaire au mali depuis le
18 août dernier et jusqu à quand alors à
quand les élections en février prochain
vraiment donc tout le monde s'accorde à
dire que les élections ne pourront pas
se tenir pour une autre raison c'est que
la situation sécuritaire quasiment 30 35
% du territoire échappe au contrôle de
l'autorité centrale donc du gouvernement
place donc des militaires et de la
communauté internationale ne pourra pas
se faire
vraisemblablement il faut rester sur le
calendrier de février pour le deuxième
tour enfin 22 février précisément pour
le deuxième tour et quinze jours plus
tard pour le deuxième tout premier tour
par dong le 22 février et 15 jours plus
tard pour le deuxième tour mais tout le
monde s'accorde à dire qu'il faudra sans
doute avoir quelques exceptions et sans
doute repoussé cette échéance
si vous m'autorisez aussi aux pas raison
on ne veut pas d'un côté dire que le
tchad doit s'appuyer sur l'exemplarité
de la cohabitation entre les militaires
et les civils
maintenant que les civils sont ont été
là ces civils ont été chassés du pouvoir
dire que l'exemple malien ne sont même
plus à un moment ou un autre si on est
rentré dans une exceptionnelle it et la
france a soutenu la transition militaire
au tchad la france a adoubé la
transition militaire en dessous dans
sanaa était il en a été évidemment
question à l'occasion du sommet sur le
financement des économies africaines le
18 mai dernier où on a effacé ou
partiellement une partie des 60
milliards de dettes ou sedan en 20 ans
l'exemplarité du partage de pouvoir
entre le conseil militaire du général
burhan et le la fonction de premier
ministre
deham docks de lame duck dupré ministre
et de l'autre dire qu'on va sanctionner
les maliens je rappelle que les
personnes qui seraient potentiellement
sanctionnable pour l'instant il n'en est
pas question en tout cas que au niveau
verbal que ce sont ces personnes qui
nous aident et qui accessoirement sont
parfois au qui sont à nos côtés et
parfois deux ans pour lutter contre les
boues par un terroriste au sahel et le
mali fait partie évidemment du g5 c'est
le côté du tchad de la mauritanie et du
burkina faso notamment à vous venez de
parler de paris quel rôle pour paris
quel rôle pour washington qui a parlé
récemment et pour la cedeao en la
communauté des états de l'afrique de
l'ouest
alors évidemment c'est la vidéo qui est
médiatrice dans cette dans cette ombre
du loup le président l'ancien président
du nigéria goodluck johnatan et à bamako
depuis maintenant deux jours
c'est lui qui doit essayer de trouver
une solution néanmoins beaucoup de deux
personnes se posent la question de
savoir si la personnalité de good job
manhattan et est idoine
ou en tout cas est légitime dans cette
configuration il s'est agit d'ailleurs
de considérer que au début de ce qui est
devenu crise il était question d'une
médiation du président en exercice de la
cédéao en l'occurrence nana akufo addo
le président du ghana
peut-être devrons-nous attendre d'ici
quelques heures vont se réunit les
quinze et chefs d'état de la cedeao vont
se réunir et c'est sans doute là que le
consensus va se faire donc loin
du mali pour essayer de trouver le nom
du successeur de moctar ouane
il semblerait que assimile doyen qui
était jusqu'à présent vice président de
la transition en charge des questions de
sécurité
card le poste de président après tout on
l'a reconnu comme tel au tchad avec la
légitimité que la france et dont seront
accordés au fils du président défunt
idriss deby en la personne de mohamed vi
et maintenant tout les regards se
portent sur la sauce le nom est la
personnification de celui qui pourrait
incarner de la primaire le poste de
premier ministre
merci emmanuel djob fait d'avoir répondu
à nos questions je rappelle que vous
êtes le président de l'ihh ps l'institut
prospective et sécurité en europe